[Applause]
Volkswagens futures seemed secure says
car tester clothes nice vids and backs
it up with a figure VW sold almost six
hundred thousand cars in September 2017
alone the most vehicles sold in a month
in the company's history
so Volkswagen did everything right there
are now new interesting models
completely new technology and of course
fuel efficient environmentally friendly
engines one vehicle with these new
technologies is this T Rock the T Rock
is based on the golf and many people
call it a gold SUV an off-road vehicle
Klaus says the way it looks and what it
offers it could make it a great success
absolute fo frettin small SUVs are a big
trend one that boasts wagon had failed
to join until now the new T Rock is now
ready to roll seldom has a new
Volkswagen seem so young and fresh but
does it drive accordingly VW says the T
Rock is the sportiest SUV in its
portfolio
the closest car has a 2-liter
turbocharged TSI gasoline engine it
cranks out 190 horsepower and has 320
Newton meters of torque
klaus is impressed with its own
volkswagen raced the t rocks top speed
at 216 kilometres an hour and its fuel
consumption at six point seven liters
per 100 kilometers of course driving
flat out on the highway will burn a
liter or two more the top model with its
140 kilowatt engine accelerates from 0
to 100 and around 7 seconds it always
comes with all-wheel drive and a 7-speed
dual-clutch transmission that's a lot of
power for the compact segment the price
for the model we're testing is thirty
thousand eight hundred euros in Germany
this all wheeler has a four motion
active control system says Klaus with a
switch to choose your driving mode for
example you can set the mode to tackle
the snow and winter a climb in the
mountains or a bumpy country road an
individual against aluminum other as is
Alice and bot
[Music]
the tea rock is not just a golf with
more ground clearance the 4.2 3 metre
long 5 door vehicle displays its
individuality with an unprecedented
shape in the range in front the
headlights are integrated almost in
grown into a wide radiator grille the
side view is characterized by bulging
wheel houses that underscore the tea
rocks off-road character the roof has a
contrasting color that adds extra
individuality it helps to distinguish
the tea rock from its brother the Audi
q2 which it otherwise resembles from the
side the surrounding plastic paneling
also emphasizes the off-road look and
suggests it has under ride protection
[Music]
the LED tail lights and seemingly
integrated exhaust trims have a modern
but unremarkable effect
[Music]
the trunk volume is typical of the
segment between 445 and 1290 liters
[Music]
the interior is as stylish as the
exterior the SUV appearance greatly
resembling the style of the Volkswagen
Golf sportsvan
can be varied to fulfill the owners
wishes the tea rocks active info display
provides digital instruments for a more
modern effect
[Music]
one exclusives and SUVs should always
have all-wheel drive that enables it to
pull a heavy trailer move better out of
a wet meta or drive a little more safely
in snowy weather all topics
one thing is clear clouds thumbs up
nowadays almost one in three new cars
sold is an SUV or crossover and that
means cars like this where they're large
or small will be the dominant sight on
the road in a few years